♪ ♪
>> I THINK THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS
INHERENT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
YES, EVEN FOR TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
>> Mike: WELCOME OF THOSE
TERRIBLE PEOPLE THAT SANDERS
THINKS SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE INCLUDE THE BOSTON
MARATHON BOMBER.
ALONG WITH CHILD RAPISTS AND
MURDERERS.
HIS PLAN IS ORDERING SHOOTING
THESE GUYS ARE SHOCKED.
>> I'M STUNNED, AS YOU CAN SEE
ON OUR FACES, AND THE RESPONSES
THAT YOU HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME,
LIKE THE BOSTON MARATHON
BOMBINGS, IF YOU HAVE ASSAULTED
OR ABUSED A CHILD, I DON'T THINK
AMERICANS -- MOST AMERICANS
WOULD WANT PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IT FRAMES,
TRIMS A PROPOSITION FOR VOTERS
AS THESE PEOPLE ARE WAY OUT
THERE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WOW, HAVE THEY GONE FAR LEFT.
>> Mike: WHEN THESE GUYS SAY
IT.
BUT HEY, IT GETS CRAZIER.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ'S CHIEF
OF STAFF NOW OFFERING HIS
THOUGHTS.
HE TWEETED THIS.
"WHAT'S THE REASON NOT TO LET
INCARCERATED PEOPLE VOTE?
SHOULDN'T THE PEOPLE MOST
AFFECTED BY UNJUST LAWS HAVE
SOME SAY IN ELECTING PEOPLE TO
CHANGE THEM?
"SO NOW WE ARE THE POINT WHERE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THINKS THE
LAWS THAT WERE THE
BOSTON MARATHON BOMBER BEHIND
BARS ARE UNJUST.
THIS SOMEHOW FAILED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IF THOSE ARE
TRULY UNJUST LAWS, IT'S UP
TO CONGRESS TO CHANGE THEM.
HERE TO DEBATE, DAVID BOSSIE,
FORMER TRUMP DEPUTY CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, AND ATTORNEY ALAN
ORR.
ALAN, I WILL START WITH YOU.
OF LOVE TO GET AN INSIGHT FROM A
DEMOCRAT, TELL ME, IS WHAT I
JUST SAW A SCENE PROPOSAL TO
THE DEMOCRATS TO RUN ON A 2020?
>> WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS SPECIFICALLY, HE
IS TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY ARTY
DO IN VERMONT AND MAINE.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE PLACE
WHERE THESE PEOPLE CAN VOTE,
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE INCARCERATED.
>> Mike: NO MATTER WHAT TYPE
OF CRIME.
MURDER, RAPE, YOU CAN VOTE WHAT
YOU ARE STILL INCARCERATED.
>> THERE ARE SOME LEVELS WHERE
PEOPLE CAN VOTE.
>> Mike: YOU THINK THAT'S
OKAY?
I'M ASKING YOU.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THE CONCEPT OF THE
PRISON SYSTEM WE HAVE COME TO
THE PRISON COMPLEX THAT WAS
BUILT, WE NEED TO ALLOW SOME
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
THERE SHOULD BE SOME PEOPLE THAT
ARE EXCLUDED BUT SPECIFICALLY
AFTER PEOPLE HAVE DONE OUR TIME,
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO VOTE.
>> Mike: AFTER THEY HAVE DONE
OUR TIME.
BIG DIFFERENCE.
IT'S DIFFERENT TO SAY AFTER YOU
HAVE DONE YOUR TIME, PROVING
YOURSELF TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
I'M ALL ABOUT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE.
I WORKED ON THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED.
UP EARLY FOR THAT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN RESTORED.
WE'RE TALKING WITH PEOPLE WHO
ARE SITTING THERE BECAUSE THEY
MURDER PEOPLE.
>> THIS IS OUTSIDE THE
MAINSTREAM.
THIS IS OUTSIDE COMMON SENSE.
BERNIE SANDERS WASN'T TALKING
JUST ABOUT VERMONT.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT ALL PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
INCARCERATED.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE NIKOLAS CRUZ,
THE PARKLAND MURDERER, WHO
MURDERED 16 KIDS IN THAT SCHOOL
AND PARK FLORIDA
WE HAVE THE SON OF SAM, STILL IN
PRISON.
OR WERE WE EXPECTING WITH THESE
PEOPLE, THE WORST OF THE WORST,
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE?
IT IS INSANE POLICY.
BUT IT IS SO GOOD FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO BE ABLE TO RUN
AGAINST THAT BECAUSE IF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL REJECT IT.
>> Mike: SPEAK TO THAT.
>> I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL REJECT THAT.
MOST PEOPLE IN JAIL NEVER WENT
TO COURT.
90%.
>> Mike: THE ISSUE IS
BERNIE SANDERS IS SAYING PEOPLE
WHO HAVE DONE EVIL THINGS -- WE
ARE TALKING THE BOSTON BOMBER --
>> YOU ARE TALKING BUT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CONVICTED.
WE KNOW THERE ARE RAPISTS AND
MURDERERS THAT VOTE EVERY DAY.
VOTING WAS NOT PART OF THEIR
CRIME.
PEOPLE CAN BE ALCOHOLICS AND
STILL BE GOOD LAWYERS.
>> Mike: GOT IT.
HERE'S A THING.
WHY DID THE DEMOCRATS WANT
INMATES TO VOTE MORE SO?
RELATING THAT MORE OF THE
INMATES ARE DEMOCRATS?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS --
I THINK WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IS
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISENFRANCHISED,
BECAUSE 30% OF THE POPULATION OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT THEY
REPRESENT 60% OF THE JAIL SO
THEREFORE THESE LAWS AND
INSTITUTIONS ARE AFFECTING THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
>> Mike: THEY WERE CONVICTED
IN A COURT OF LAW.
>> HOLD ON.
WHEN YOU ARE IN PRISON, YOU LOSE
YOUR RIGHT OF ASSEMBLY, YOU LOSE
YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT.
YOU LOSE A LOT OF RIGHTS.
>> Mike: YOU LOSE YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> YOU LOSE YOUR RIGHT TO VOTE.
THAT IS WHAT LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS GET TO DO.
THOSE THAT ARE INCARCERATED DO
NOT AND THEY OUGHT NOT TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE AND THEY OUGHT
NOT -- LOOK.
THIS IS A CONVERSATION WE ARE